Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Buonasera a tutti.
Io ho pensato di cominciare
questo intervento con una domanda:
voi avete mai sentito parlare
di "dati non collegati"?
I dati non collegati
sono i dati che descrivono un evento
ma non dicono a chi è capitato,
ad esempio, non so, una visita medica:
dicono tutto su quello
che è stato fatto durante la visita,
ma non c'è l'identificativo del paziente;
e nei dati collegati, invece,
c'è un identificativo
che può essere un identificativo
anonimo, magari,
ma che comunque consente, poi,
di riferire i vari eventi
alla stessa persona.
E la distinzione è importante,
perché tantissime decisioni
che ci riguardano -
faccio qualche esempio:
se uno ha una patologia all'anca,
la decisione se ricorrere a una protesi;
se qualcuno cerca casa, la decisione
se e di quanto la banca
deve concedergli il mutuo,
e a che condizioni;
o magari, anche, se qualcuno
è condannato per un reato lieve,
se sia il caso o no di proporre
l'affidamento ai servizi sociali.
Questo tipo di decisioni,
che prima erano prese
qualitativamente da persone,
adesso sono sempre più
affiancate da dei modelli,
e questi modelli sono modelli
di Intelligenza Artificiale,
un modo un po' pomposo
per dire che sono modelli
che imparano sulla base di esempi,
gli si presentano degli esempi
di situazioni che sono
avvenute nel passato,
di decisioni buone o cattive
che sono state prese nel passato,
e il modello impara a generalizzare
partendo dagli esempi,
e quindi poi a suggerire una decisione
che, si spera, sia migliore di quella
che verrebbe presa in modo quantitativo.
Ecco: una cosa che ci si
potrebbe domandare
è se questi modelli,
che sono quindi addestrati
sulla base di esempi, di dati,
debbano usare dati collegati
oppure dati non collegati.
Il problema del dato collegato
è che è vero che può essere anonimo,
cioè ha un identificatore anonimo dentro.
Ma chi conosce un po' il contesto
in cui il dato è stato prelevato,
tante volte riesce a risalire
all'identità della persona
che in qualche modo
è oggetto di quella rilevazione.
E quindi, non voglio rispondere
alla domanda adesso:
vorrei raccontarvi invece una storia,
perché la storia illustra un pochino
la risposta alla domanda.
La storia è cominciata
nel gennaio del 2020:
io vado ad Abu Dhabi, ed ero bloccato lì
perché con la pandemia
non si poteva viaggiare.
E sono stato coinvolto
dalla mia università
in un progetto, che dovevamo proporre,
sulla stima, appunto -
come si diceva poco fa -
dell'impatto del contagio.
Ci veniva chiesta una previsione
a due settimane, tre settimane,
quattro settimane
di quante sarebbero state
le persone contagiate.
Ci abbiamo pensato un attimo,
e ci è venuta l'idea
di, appunto, partire dai dati,
i dati di posizione,
le cosiddette "tracce digitali"
che oggi non lasciano le persone,
ma le lasciano i telefonini.
Attenzione, vorrei chiarire:
non sono i dati di posizione del GPS,
che usiamo nelle mappe:
tutti noi li usiamo.
Perché quelli sono calcolati
sul telefonino:
e quindi, per poterli rendere noti,
bisogna che il padrone del telefonino
ne autorizzi l'uso,
e quindi per definizione
si tratta di dati parziali.
No, no, noi parliamo proprio dei quei dati
che la rete cellulare sa su di noi:
sa a quale cella a cui siamo collegati.
Anzi, per la verità oggi come oggi
non sono proprio celle:
sanno un po' meglio la nostra posizione
all'interno di un pixel,
un quadratino all'interno di una cella
che può avere qualche decina
di metri di lato.
Ecco: quelle che vedete
dietro le mie spalle
sono proprio queste tracce digitali
che sono presenti nei database,
negli archivi dei gestori
dei telefonini, delle reti cellulari.
E allora noi abbiamo detto:
mettiamo insieme queste tracce digitali,
che sono complete, riguardano
tutti i telefoni di tutti -
negli Emirati ci sono soltanto due
principali operatori di rete cellulare -
mettiamo insieme questi dati
con altre due elementi.
Un elemento sono le mappe:
noi sappiamo, di questi quadratini,
sappiamo questi quadratini dove sono,
a quali zone della città corrispondono.
Qui, dietro le mie spalle, vedete adesso
che è divisa in questi pixel,
in questi quadratini,
la città di Abu Dhabi.
È, come vedete, una città
fatta di isole sul mare.
E per ciascun quadratino so, anche,
se è all'aperto o se è al chiuso.
So se è parte di un supermercato,
o di una casa di abitazione,
so cosa ci succede;
e quindi, in qualche maniera,
con questo elemento io posso tarare
una formula empirica,
una formula che si chiama
"Formula di Brooks".
Brooks era il direttore
del Centro di Contrasto
alle Malattie Infettive
negli Stati Uniti,
e sostanzialmente questa formula ci dice
qual è la probabilità di essere contagiati
quando siamo nello stesso pixel
di uno che ha già preso una malattia.
Questo dipende dal tempo che ci stiamo;
e anche dipende da alcune condizioni,
ad esempio la velocità
di trasferimento della massa virale
tra l'infetto e le altre persone.
Questa velocità dipende
se siamo all'aperto, se siamo al chiuso,
se c'è vento oppure no.
E poi, anche, dipende
dalla variante del virus.
Qui vedete una variante recente:
quando noi siamo partiti,
la Regola di Brooks
parlava di 15 minuti
per un pixel al chiuso.
E oggi come oggi, questa
è una versione più recente del virus
che è diventato più abile,
quindi con meno massa virale trasferita
causa già il contagio,
e pertanto il tempo
che è richiesto di contatto,
che è richiesto per trasmettere
questo contagio,
è molto inferiore.
Comunque dovevamo mettere insieme
questi tre elementi:
e attraverso questi tre elementi,
sapendo dove le persone andavano,
per quanto tempo rimanevano insieme
all'interno dei pixel,
volevamo prevedere quanto sarebbe stato
il trasferimento di massa virale:
e quindi anche, collettivamente,
quale sarebbe stato l'impatto
dal punto di vista
del numero di persone contagiate.
E ci siamo messi a lavorare
in questa direzione;
finché non c'è venuto
in mente che, in fondo,
i dati sulla mobilità delle persone
non sono dati qualunque.
Sapere dove io mi trovo,
e quanto tempo ci sono rimasto
in vari momenti della giornata,
è un dato che è abbastanza sensibile.
È vero che gli operatori di rete mobile,
cioè i fornitori dei servizi, lo sanno,
ma noi glielo abbiamo rivelato
solo per poter gestire la rete.
Anche le forze dell'ordine
possono saperlo;
ma ci vuole l'autorizzazione
di un magistrato,
ci vuole il motivo per chiederlo.
Quindi,
passare ad un monitoraggio generalizzato
della mobilità delle persone,
anche se ci avesse dato
un modello molto efficace -
be', ci siamo fermati un attimo.
E abbiamo deciso di fare
in modo un pochino diverso.
Quello che vedete qui,
quello che abbiamo fatto
è stato innanzitutto di usare
i dati non collegati,
cioè di prendere i dati e di dimenticarci,
anzi non farci nemmeno dire
dagli operatori telefonici,
l'identificatore a cui appartenevano.
Sappiamo che c'erano dei telefonini
nelle varie celle,
ma non sappiamo se era lo stesso
da un evento con il successivo.
E poi abbiamo usato
questi dati non collegati
non per seguirli, ma per tarare
degli utenti simulati.
Questi utenti - quindi abbiamo un modello
che genera degli utenti simulati
che però, statisticamente,
si comportano come quelli veri.
E udite udite,
le previsioni di contagio
fatte con questo modello
sono di ottima qualità,
tanto che adesso lo utilizziamo
per stimare il rischio che deriva
dagli arrivi transfrontalieri,
cioè quando atterra un aereo,
quando arriva una nave,
le persone che sono a bordo si aggiungono
e il modello di mobilità
mi dice qual è il rischio
se queste persone fossero infette,
quanti altri casi potrebbero provocare
nel giro di una settimana,
nel giro di 15 giorni.
La storia ve l'ho raccontata
non tanto per attirare
l'attenzione sul modello,
quanto per attirare
l'attenzione sulla morale.
E qual è la morale?
La morale è che noi abbiamo
il diritto di domandarci
se l'informazione che trasferiamo
a chi deve applicare dei modelli,
anche utili a tutti,
se l'informazione che noi trasferiamo
e in quantità adeguata.
Esiste un "Principio di minimalità"
che dice che l'informazione
che dovremmo trasferire
è quella strettamente necessaria
per fare la cosa che ci viene promessa.
Ed è molto importante
che noi sappiamo di questo principio;
e sappiamo anche che, a volte,
i dati non collegati
sono più che sufficienti,
i dati generati sono più che sufficienti.
Se quella app che abbiamo,
magari "Salute e Bellezza",
che abbiamo nel nostro telefonino,
raccoglie dati sul nostro comportamento,
e ci chiede il permesso
di condividerli in forma anonima,
la differenza tra l'anonimato
e il dato non collegato
spero che, dopo stasera,
molti che non si occupano
di cose tecnologiche
ce l'abbiano in mente.
E come possiamo fare per trasferire?
Ecco, qui vedete il nostro modello
come popola i contagi
sulla base di uno sbarco
da parte di un gruppo di persone.
Ma come facciamo noi
a chiedere, esplicitamente,
che venga rispettato
il Principio di Minimalità?
Lo possiamo fare
perché le app che noi utilizziamo,
che abbiamo nei nostri cellulari,
hanno tutte, per normative,
una politica di gestione dei dati.
E questa politica può essere vista,
è a disposizione nostra
per poterla consultare.
E basterebbe che noi
chiedessimo di consultarla,
oppure che, quando ci viene proposta
dall'applicazione,
non cliccassimo "Accetto,
accetto, accetto",
ma semplicemente lasciassimo passare
un po' di tempo tra un click e successivo,
e vedreste che qualche
Intelligenza Artificiale
del fornitore dell'applicazione
si accorgerebbe che gli utenti
stanno leggendo,
e sono attenti alle condizioni
con cui viene fornita l'informazione
per consentire al modello di funzionare.
Il controllo sulle informazioni
che forniamo, anche per una causa giusta,
deve rimanere con la fonte,
non dimentichiamolo mai.
Grazie.
(Applausi)